ازمه تفاقم يناقلات النفط في الموانئ
التركيه تثير غضب الغرب ودول الاتحاد
الاوروبي التي تعاني اصلا من نقص كبير في
الطاقه مع دخول فصل الشتاء قارس
نجري اتصالات مع السلطات التركيه للحصول
على توضيحات ونعمل على حل الواضح
الولايات المتحده انتقدت هي الاخرى تصرفات
انقره
الاداره الامريكيه لا ترى مبررا لتطبيق
الاجراءات التركيه الجديده على شحنات
النفط
البعض اتهم تركيا بانها اصبحت حجر عثره
امام خطه دوليه معقده لحرمان روسيا من
عائدات النفط بسبب حربها ضد اوكرانيا مع
استمرار ارتفاع عدد الناقلات التي تنتظر
الخروج من البحر الاسود عبر مضيقين تركيين
لكن تركيا تتجاهل دعوات السماح للناقلات
بالتحرك حتى اللحظه وتصر على المضيء في
اجراءتها السلطات البحريه التركيه اعلنت
رفض الغائها قاعده فحص التامين الجديده
التي طبقتها في بدايه الشهر رغم الغرب
بالاضافه الى مواصله منع ناقلات النفط
التي لا تحمل خطابات التامين المناسبه من
دخول مياهها
الالتزام بتطبيق ما اتفقت مجموعه السبع
والاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا على تصدير
النفط الروسي وفقا لسقف سعري المحدد في
حاله وقوع حادث لسفينه انتهق العقوبات فمن
المحتمل الا يغطي صندوق عالمي معني بتسرب
النفط تكلفه الاضرار
المفوضيه الاوروبيه رات ان التاخير غير
مرتبط بالسقف السعري وان تركيا لا يمكنها
التحقق من وثائق التامين كما في السابق
فيما قالت وكالات الشحن وابرزها تريبيكا
ان عدد ناقلات النفط التي تنتظر عبور
مضيقي الباسبور والدردنيل ارتفع الى 28
وسط مخاوف لدى شركات التامين الغربيه
المسؤوله عن تلك الناقلات من تقديم
الوثائق لتركيا لانها ربما ستتعرض له
عقوبات اذا تبين ان شحنات النفطه التي
تغطيها بيعه باسعار تتجاوز السقف السحري
ومع استمرار منعي سفن النفط من مغادره
الموانئ التركيه يزداد غضب حلفاء انقره في
الغرب التي تنتظره وصول كميه كبيره من
النفط الى موانع الاتحاد الاوروبي واصطم
خوفه من ان تكدس السفن سيتسبب في صعوبات
متزايده في اسواق النفط والناقلات جاسم
محسن العربيه